[Music]
hello i'm erielle khan with the future
of life Institute as you may have seen
this month we announced a pledge against
lethal autonomous weapons the pledge
calls upon governments and government
leaders to create a future with strong
international norms regulations and laws
against lethal autonomous weapons but in
the meantime signatories agreed that
they will neither participate in nor
support for development manufacture
trade or use of lethal autonomous
weapons
at the time of this recording over 220
AI related organizations and over 2,800
individuals have signed signatories
include google deepmind and its founders
university college london the XPrize
foundation clear path robotics silicon
valley robotics the european association
for artificial intelligence and many
other AI societies and organizations
from around the world additionally
people who signed include Elon Musk
Google's head of research and machine
learning Jeff Dean many prominent AI
researchers such as Stuart Russell
Toby Walsh Meredith Whittaker on the
dragon Joshua Ben geo and even
politicians like British MP Alex Sobel
but why we've all seen the movies and
read the books about AI gone wrong and
yet most of the signatories agree that
the last thing they're worried about is
malicious AI no one thinks the
terminator is in our future so why are
so many people in the world of AI so
worried about lethal autonomous weapons
the short answer is it's complicated for
the longer answer we have this podcast
for this podcast I spoke with six of
leading experts in autonomous weapons
I spoke with defense expert Paul sureiy
who recently released the book army of
none autonomous weapons in the future of
war we discussed the history of
autonomous weapons and semi autonomous
weaponry which dates back to world war
ii as well as some of the more nuanced
issues today that often come up for
debate
AI researcher toby walsh looks at lethal
autonomous weapons from a more technical
perspective considering the impact of
autonomous weapons on society and also
the negative effects they could have for
AI researchers if AI technology is used
to kill people Richard Morris with
article 36 coined the phrase meaningful
human control which is what much of the
laws debate at the United Nations now
focuses on he describes what that means
and why it's important
Mary Wareham and Bonnie Daugherty joined
from Human Rights Watch and they're also
founders of the campaign to stop killer
robots they talk about the humanitarian
impact of lethal autonomous weapons and
they explain the process going on at the
United Nations today as efforts move
towards ban finally my interviews end
with Peter Rosario with the
International Committee for
arms control and also the campaign to
stop killer robots peter considers the
issue of laws from an ethical and legal
standpoint looking at the impact killer
robots could have on everything from
human dignity to war crimes but all at
each of them introduce themselves better
when their interviews begin and because
this podcast is so long in the
description we've included the times
that each interview starts so that you
can more easily jump around or listen to
sections as you have time one quick
final point to mention is that everyone
was kind enough to join at the last
minute which means not all the audio is
perfect most of it is fine but please
bear with us if you can hear people
chattering in the background or any
other similar imperfections and now for
the first interview with Paul Sciarra
I'm Paul short I'm a senior fellow and
director of the technology and national
security program at the Center for new
American security or a Washington
dc-based national security think tank
that's an independent bipartisan
research organization and you have a
background in weaponry you were in the
military correct yeah so I served about
five and a half years in the US Army as
Ranger and civil affairs team leader and
I did multiple tours to Iraq and
Afghanistan and then I worked for
several years after that in the Pentagon
in the office of the secretary of
defense or actually worked on policy
issues for emerging weapons technologies
including us harness weapons okay and so
one of the very first questions that I
want to start with is how do you define
an autonomous weapon I mean that's sort
of the million dollar question in a lot
of ways and I don't want to imply that
all of the debate around autonomous
weapons is a misunderstanding of
semantics that's not true at all there
are clearly people with very different
views on what to do about the technology
but it is a big complicating factor
because I have certainly seen especially
at the United Nations very heated
disagreements where it's clear that
people are just talking past each other
in terms of what they're envisioning
when you say the term autonomous weapon
it conjures all sorts of different ideas
in people's minds
some people envisioning
super advanced intelligent machines that
have human-like or superhuman
intelligence something like a terminator
or Cylon from science fiction and other
people are envisioning something might
be very simple and doable today like a
Roomba with a gun on it and both of
those things are probably really bad
ideas but for very different kinds of
reasons and I think that that's a
complicating factor so one of the
dimensions of autonomy that people tend
to get fixated on is how smart the
weapon system is I actually don't think
that that's a useful way to define an
autonomous weapon sometimes I've heard
people say things like well you know
this is not an autonomous weapon it's an
automated weapon because of the level of
sophistication and I don't think that's
very helpful I think it's much better
actually to focus on the functions that
the weapon is performing on its own this
is similar to the approach that the
International Committee of the Red Cross
has which focuses on critical functions
in weapon systems the way that I defined
it in my book is I basically define an
autonomous weapon as one that can
complete an entire engagement cycle on
its own that is to say there's all of
the functionality needed to search for
targets to identify them to make a
decision about whether or not to attack
them and then to start the engagement
and carry through the engagement all by
itself so there's no human in this loop
this cognitive loop of sensing and
deciding and acting up in the
battlefield all by itself that defines
it in such a way that there are some
things and this is what gets into some
of the tricky definitional issues there
are weapons that have been around since
World War two that I would call semi
autonomous weapons they have some degree
of autonomy they have some sensors on
board they can detect the enemy and they
can make some rudimentary kinds of
actions like maneuvering towards the
enemy militaries generally called these
homing munitions their torpedoes or air
missiles or surface-to-air air-to-ground
missiles and they have sensors on them
that might use sonar or radar or
acoustic signatures and they can sense
that the enemy's there and then they use
those sensors to maneuver towards the
enemy to strike the target these are
generally launched by people at targets
where the human knows there's a target
there these were originally invented in
World War two
by the Germans to hit Allied ships in
the submarine wars in the Atlantic in
World War two and you can imagine
there's a technical challenge of trying
to hit a moving target of a ship it's
moving in a submarine trying to fire a
torpedo at it and you might miss and so
the first versions of these had
microphones that could listen to the
sound of the propellers from Allied
ships and then steer towards where the
sound was greatest so they could hit the
ship and so in those cases and this is
still the case those that are used today
humans see the target or have some
indication of the target may be from a
radar or sonar signature and humans say
there's something out there I want to
launch this weapon to go attack it and
those have been around for 70 years or
so and I bring that up because there are
some people who sometimes say well look
these at times happens already exist
this is all a bunch of hullabaloo about
nothing I don't think that's really true
I think that a lot of the weapon systems
that you see concern about going forward
would be things that would be quite
qualitatively different things that are
going out over a wide area and searching
for targets on their own where humans
don't necessarily know where the enemy
is they might have some suspicion that
the enemy might be in this area at this
point in time but they don't know and
they launch the weapon to then find the
enemy and then without radioing back to
a human for approval that weapon is
delegated authority to attack on its own
by and large we don't see weapons like
this in existence today there are some
exceptions the Israeli harpy drone or
luring munition is an exception there
were a couple experimental u.s. systems
in the 80s and 90s that are no longer in
service but this isn't something that's
in widespread use and so I do think the
debate about where are we going in the
future is that it's a very valid one and
we are on the cusp of potentially things
that would be quite different than
anything we've seen before warfare so I
wouldn't ask a quick question about the
heartbeat and any other type of weapon
similar to that I have those actually
been used to kill anyone yet to actually
identify target and kill some enemy or
are they still just being used for
identifying and
potentially targeting people but it's
still a human who is making the final
decision it's a great question to the
best of my knowledge the Israeli harpy
has not been used in its fully
autonomous mode in combat and so a
couple things about how the herpe
functions first of all it doesn't target
people per se targets radars now having
said that if a person is standing next
to a Raider that it targets you know
you're probably going to be killed but
it's not it's not looking for individual
persons it's looking for radar
signatures and then zeroing in on them I
mentioned that as important for two
reasons one sometimes in some of the
concerns that people raised about
autonomous weapons it can sometimes be
unclear at least to like a listener
whether they are concerned about
specifically weapons that were target
humans or any weapon that might target
you know where anything on the
battlefield and so that's I think one
consideration but also from sort of a
practicality standpoint it is easier to
identify radio signatures more
accurately than people who of course in
many modern conflicts are not wearing
uniforms or insignia or the things that
might clearly identify them as a combat
and so a lot of the issues around
distinction and accurately
discriminating between combatants in
that combatants are hard for weapons
that were target people but the answer
to question is a little bit tricky
because there was an incident a couple
years ago where a second-generation
version of the heart be called The
Herald or heart b2 was used in the
nagorno-karabakh region in the conflict
there between Azerbaijan and Armenia I
think it was used by Azerbaijan and used
to attack what looked like a I believe
it was a bus full of fighters now by all
accounts the incident was one of actual
militants being targeted combatants not
civilians but heroes accused was clearly
not a radar it was a bus that would not
have been emitting radar signatures
based on my understanding of how the
technology works the hair up the car p2
has a human in the loop mode so the
first generation harpy as far as I
understand is all autonomous the second
generation version definitely as a human
mode looks like it's not clear whether
also has an autonomous version
when writing the book I've reached out
to the manufacturer for more details on
this and they were not particularly
forthcoming but in that instance it
looks like it was probably directed by a
human that attack because as far as we
know the weapon does not have the
ability to autonomously target something
like a bus okay it's a really
long-winded answer and this is what
actually makes this issue super hard
sometimes because they depend a lot on
the technical specifications of the
weapon which they are complicated if
you're like not always very transparent
I mean companies are not always very
transparent publicly about how their
weapon systems function and one can
understand why that is right they don't
want adversaries to come up with methods
of fooling them and countermeasures on
the other hand for people who are
interested in understanding how
companies are pushing the bounds of
autonomy that could be very frustrating
one of the things that I really like
about the way you think is that it is
very nuanced and takes into account a
lot of these different issues and I
think it's tempting and easy and I don't
want to make it sound like I'm being
lazy because I personally support
banning lethal autonomous weapons but I
think it's a really complicated issue
and so as I'd like to know more about
what are your thoughts on a band so
there are two areas on this topic that I
think was work it's really complicated
and really tricky so if you start with a
broad principle that someone might have
something like humans should be making
decisions about lethal force or you know
only humans should be deciding to take
human life there's two areas where you
try to figure out how do I put them into
practice and then you really run into
some serious challenges and another
thing that makes it impossible because
difficulty has a sort of really roll up
your sleeves and get into some of the
details of the issue so one is how do
you translate a broad concept like that
into technical specifications of a
weapon so if you start with that idea
and say well only humans should be
responsible for taking human life that
seems like a reasonable idea okay how do
you translate that into technical
guidance that you give weapons
developers over what they can and cannot
build that's actually really hard and I
say that as having done this when I
worked at the Pentagon and we tried to
write guidance that was really
designed to be internal to the US
Defense Department to give guidance to
defense companies into military
researchers on what they could build and
it was hard to transit some of these
abstract concepts like humans should
decide the targets too technical ideas
well what does that mean for how long
the weapon can lower over target area or
how big its sensor field should be or
how long it can search for and some of
those you have to try to figure out how
to put those technical characteristics
into practice it may give you two
examples of a weapon in this illustrate
how this can be challenging you might
imagine a weapon today where a human
says here's an enemy target and I want
to take that target out and a bunch of
missile and the missile flies towards
the target let's say it's a tank and the
missile uses a millimeter wave seeker on
the tank it's an active seeker sends a
millimeter wave radar signatures to see
the tank and illustrate it and sort of
highlight it from the background and
then zero in on a tank because it's
moving and they need to have this sensor
to hit the moody tank if the weapon and
the sensor can only search for a very
limited space in time and geography then
you've constrained the autonomy enough
that the human is still in control of
what its targeting but as you start to
open that aperture up and maybe it's no
longer that it's searching for one
minute in a one kilometer area it's not
searching for eight hours over a
thousand kilometers now you have a
completely different kind of weapon
system right now it's one it's much more
like I make the analogy in the book of
the difference between a police dog that
might be set loose to go chase down a
suspect where the human says there's the
suspect dog go get them versus a mad dog
roaming the streets attacking anyone it
will you've two different paradigms but
where do you draw the line in between
and where do you say well you know is
one minute of lord or time is it two
minutes is a 10 minutes into 20 minutes
what's the geographic area it's going to
depend a lot on the target the
environment what kind of clutters in the
environment what might be an appropriate
answer for tanks in an urban combat
setting might be very different than
naval ships
on the high seas or submarines
underwater or some other target a
different environment so that's one
challenge and then the other challenge
of course which is even more contested
is just sort of what's the feasibility
of a band and getting countries to come
together to actually agree to things
because ultimately countries have
militaries because they don't trust each
other they don't trust international law
to constrain other countries from
aggressive action so regardless of
whether you you favor one country or
another you consider yourself an
American or Russian or a Chinese or
French or Israeli or Ghanaian or someone
else countries in general that militares
cuz they don't trust others then that
makes even if you could choose to sign
up to a ban that's a major challenge
getting people to actually adhere to
then because they're always countries
are always fearful about others breaking
these rules and cheating and getting the
upper hand I mean we have had other
bands email we've been biological
weapons chemical weapons land mines
space weapons do you see this as
different somehow yeah so one of the
things that go through my book is as
comprehensive as I could come up with a
list of all of the attempts to regulate
and control emerging technologies dating
back to antiquity dating back to ancient
Indian prohibitions in Hindu loss of
money or the Mahabharata on poisoned and
barbed arrows and fire to weapons and
it's really a mixed bag I like to see
that there's sort of enough examples of
both successes and failures people to
kind of pick whichever examples that
want for whatever side they're arguing
for because there aren't many examples
of successful bands and I would say
largely successful right there are some
examples of isolated instances of people
not adhering to them very few bands are
universally adhere to
We certainly have Bashar al-assad using
chemical weapons in Syria today but
bands that have been largely successful
and that they've at least had a major
effect in reducing these weapons include
land mines cluster munitions blinding
lasers by lunch for weapons chemical
weapons using the environment as a
weapon placing nuclear weapons on the
seabed or in orbit placing any weapons
of any kind on the moon or Antarctica
various regulations during the Cold War
anti-ballistic missile systems
intermediate range nuclear
crown launched
and then of course regulations on the
number of nuclear weapons so there are
there are a lot of successful examples
now on the other side of the coin there
are failed attempts to ban famously push
the crossbow and that's often brought up
in these conversations but in more
recent memory attempts at the 20th
century to ban and regulate aircraft and
air delivered weapons submarine warfare
of course the failure of attempts to ban
poison gas in World War one so there are
examples and other sides of the ledger
as well one of the things that I try to
do in my book is get beyond sort of just
picking examples that people like and
say well is there a pattern here are
there some common conditions that make
certain bands more likely to succeed or
fail and there's been great scholarship
done by some others before me that I was
able to build on Rebecca krutov and
Shawn Welsh they don't work on this
trying to identify some common patterns
and I think that's a if you want to look
at this analytically that's a fruitful
place to start is to say why does some
band succeed in some fail and then when
you're looking at any new technology
whether it's autonomous weapons or
something else where do they kind of
fall on the spectrum and what does that
suggest about the feasibility of certain
attempts at regulation versus others and
so can you expand on that a little bit I
mean what have you found or what have
they found in terms of patterns for
success versus failure for a ban so I
think there's a couple of criteria that
seemed to matter one is the clarity of a
ban is really crucial everyone needs to
have a clear agreement on what is in and
what is out and the simpler and clearer
the definition is the better and in some
cases this principle is actually baked
into the way that certain treaties are
written and I think the ban on Cluster
Munitions is a great example of this
where the cluster munition convention
has a very very simple principle in the
treaty it says cluster nations are
banned . now if you go into the
definition now there's all sorts of
nuance about what constitutes or
customization or not and that's where
they get into some of the horse trading
with countries ahead of time but sort of
the principle is no Cluster Munitions
the archetype of this importance of
clarity comes in the success of
restraint among European powers in using
chemical weapons against each other on
World War
all sides had done they didn't use them
on the battlefield against each other of
course you might use them in the
Holocaust and there were some other
isolated instances in World War two of
use against others didn't have them but
the European powers all had tens of
thousands of tons of mustard gas
stockpiled and then he used them against
each other at the answers of World War
two there were also attempts to restrain
aerial bombing of cities it was widely
viewed as reprehensible it was also a
beagle under international law at the
time and there were attempts on all
sides to refrain from that and at the
élysée of the war in fact they did and
Hitler actually put our directive to the
Luftwaffe and I talked about this a
little bit in the book although
unfortunately detail on some of this
I've got cut for space which I was
disappointed by give the product
directly to the Luftwaffe saying that
they were not to engage in bombing of
civilian targets a terror bombing in
Britain Orlan engage in bombing military
targets not because it was a
humanitarian because it was concerned
about Britain right Ally and this
attempt at restraint failed when in the
middle of the night a German bomber
strode off course and bomb central
London by mistake and in retaliation
Churchill ordered the bombing of Berlin
and Hitler was incensed to give his
speech the following day announcing the
launch of the London Blitz and so here's
an example where there was some some
slippage in the principle of what was
allowed and what was not and so you had
some sand a little bit of accidental
crossing of the line in conflict and so
you know the sharper and clearer this
line is the better I think it's likely
you can extrapolate them say it's likely
if for example what world war two Powers
had agreed to in war two was that they
could only use poison gas against
military targets but not against
civilian targets that it would have
quickly escalated to civilian targets as
well and in the context of autonomous
weapons that's one of the arguments why
you've seen some advocates of abandon
see that they don't support what is
sometimes called a partition treaty
which is something that would be created
Geographic partition that would say you
know you could only use a tongs weapons
outside of populated areas and what some
advocates of a ban have said is look
that's never gonna that's never gonna
hole in coin that sounds good I've heard
some international humanitarian lawyers
say that oh well this is how we solve
this problem but in practice that's I
agree that that's not likely to be very
feasible so clarity is important but
another fact
is the relative value of the military
value of weapon versus it's perceived
horribleness and I think again a good
case in point here is the difference in
the international community success in
largely getting most countries to give
up chemical weapons but the lack of
success on nuclear weapons nuclear
weapons by any reasonable measure are
far more terrible in terms of their
immediate and long lasting effects on
human life and the environment but they
have much more military value is
perceived military value and so
countries are much more reluctant to
keep them up so that's another factor
and then there are some other ones that
I think are fairly straightforward but
also mattre things like the access to
the weapon and the number of actors that
are needed to get agreement if only two
countries have the technology it's
easier to get them on board than if it's
widely available and sort of everyone
needs to agree but I think those are
some really important factors that are
significant one of the things I think
that actually doesn't matter that much
is the legality of a weapons treaty
i'ma think it's not matter at all but
you see plenty of examples of legally
binding treaties that are violated in
wartime and you see some examples not a
ton but some examples of mutual
restraint among countries when there is
no legally binding agreement or
sometimes no agreement at all no written
agreement it's sort of a tacit agreement
to refrain from certain types of
competition or uses of weapons and so
all of those I think are really
important factors when you think about
the likelihood of a ban actually
succeeding on any weapon such as tons
with any weapons but I like things of AB
and actually succeeding in wartime I'm
probably going to come back to this but
you mentioned something that reminded me
of another question I had for you and
that is in your book you mentioned oh I
don't remember what the weapon was but
it was essentially an autonomous weapon
that the military chose not to use and
ended up giving up because it was so
costly and ultimately they didn't trust
it to make the right decisions and I'm
interested in this idea of the extent to
which we trust the weapons to do
whatever it is that they're tasked with
if they're in some sort of autonomous
mode and I guess where we stand today
with various weapons and whether
military will have increasing trust in
their weapon
in the future the case of the I think
you referring to was an anti-ship
missile called the tomahawk anti-ship
missile or TASM that was in service by
the US Navy in the 1980s and it was Bari
classified as an autonomous weapon it
was designed to go over the horizon to
attack Soviet ships and it could fly a
search pattern and I think actually in
the book I included the graphic of this
search pattern that it would fly to look
for Soviet ships so the concern was that
the way this would work in an anti-ship
or anti-surface warfare is the Navy
would send out patrol aircraft because
they have they're much faster they're
much longer range than ships and they
would scout for other enemy ships the
principle in a wartime environment is
patrol aircraft would find a Soviet ship
and then radio back to a destroy the
Soviet ships location and this road
would launch a missile now the problem
was by the time the missile got there
the ship would have moved so the ship
would now have what the Miller would
call an area of uncertainty that the
ship might be in they wouldn't have the
ability to continuously track the ship
and so what they basically would do is
the missile would fly a search pattern
over this area of uncertainty and when
it found the ship would attack it now at
the time in the 1980s the technology was
not particularly advanced and it wasn't
very good at discriminating you to
different kinds of ships and so one of
the concerns was that if there happened
to be another kind of ship in the area
that was not an enemy combatant it still
might attack it if it was within this
search pattern area and again it's
originally cued by a human having some
indication of something there but there
was enough uncertainty that it flies his
pattern on its own and I am for that
reason call it autonomous weapon because
there was a great amount of uncertainty
about what it might hit and whether it
might do so accurately and it could once
launch it would sort of find and then
attack while on its own and so it was
never used and there was great hesitancy
about it being used and I interview a
retired US Navy officer who was familiar
with it at the time can he talks about
sort of that they just didn't they
didn't trust that his targeting was good
enough that once they let it loose that
it might hit the right target and
moreover there was this the secondary
problem which is they might hit the
wrong target sort of a false positive if
you will but it all
my miss the Soviet ship in which case
they would have simply wasted a weapon
system and that's another problem that
militaries have which is you know
missiles are costly they don't have very
many of them and their inventory
particularly if it's something like a
ship or an aircraft there's only so many
that they can carry physically on board
and she doesn't want to waste them for
no good reason which is another
practical sort of operational
consideration so eventually was taken
out of service for all of these for what
I understand to be all of these reasons
and it's a little bit of guesswork I
should say as to why it was taken out of
service I don't have any official
documentation saying that but that's the
least I think a reasonable assumption
about some of the motivating factors
based on talking to people who are
familiar with it at the time one of the
things that I think is is an important
dynamic that I talked about in the book
which is that that is really an acute
problem the wasting the weapon problem
for missiles that are not recoverable
you launch it you're not going to get it
back if they're if they're enemy's not
there then you've just wasted this thing
that changes dramatically if you have a
drone that can return back now all of
the concerns about hitting wrong
targeted civilian casualities those
still exist and those are very much on
the minds at least Western military
professionals who are concerned about
civilian casualties and countries that
care about the rule of law more broadly
but it's this issue of wasting the
weapon is less of an issue when you're
something that's recoverable and you can
send out on patrol and so I think it's
possible this is that publicist but it's
possible that has received more drones
and combat drones in particular being
put into service and being intended to
be used in contested areas whether it
may have Jam communications that we
start to see that dynamic change to your
question about trust I guess I'd say
that there is a lot of concern at least
among the militants that I talked to you
in the United States and in other allied
countries NATO countries or Australia or
Japan that there was a lot of concern
about trust in these systems and in fact
I see much more confidence I'm gonna
make a broad generalization here okay so
forgive me but I in general I would say
that I see much more confidence in the
technology coming from the engineers who
are building them at military research
labs or at defense companies then in the
military professionals and you won't
have to push the button and use them
that they're a little bit more skeptical
of wanting to actually trust these and
delegate them
what they see is their responsibility to
this machine what do you envision sort
of if we go down current trajectories as
the future of weaponry specifically as
it relates to autonomous weaponry and
potentially lethal autonomous weaponry
and to what extent do you think that
international agreements could change
that trajectory and maybe even to what
extent do you think countries might
possibly even appreciate having
guidelines to work within
I'll answer the first weekend
observation about most of the dialogue
in this space there's sort of two
different questions wrapped up in there
what is the likely outcome of a future
of autonomous weapons is it a good
future or a bad future and then another
one is what is the feasibility of some
kind of international attempts to
control or regulate or limit these
weapons is that possible or unlikely to
succeed and where I tend to hear is that
people on all sides of this issue tend
to cluster into two camps they tend to
either say look at on symptoms are
horrible and they're gonna cause all
these terrible effects but if we just
all get together we can bang them and
all we need to do is just I don't know
what's wrong with countries need to sit
down and sign a treaty we'll get really
these things and the problems with
itself other people in the opposite camp
say
bands don't work and anyways autonomous
weapons would be great wouldn't they be
wonderful they could make war so great
and humans wouldn't make mistakes
anymore and no innocent people will be
killed and will be safe and humane and
pristine and those those things don't
necessarily go together right so it's
entirely possible but if you look at
sort of imagine like a 2 by 2 matrix
like it's really convenient that
everybody's views fit into those boxes
very harmoniously but it but it's made
impossible I suspect that on the whole
autonomous weapons that have no human
control over targeting are not likely to
make war better it's hard for me to see
how that would be a better thing I can
see why militaries might want them in
some instances I think some of the
claims about the military values might
be overblown but there are certainly
some situations we can imagine they'd be
valuable I think it's kind of remains to
be seen how valuable and what context
but you can imagine that but in general
I think that humans add a lot of value
to making decisions about lethal force
and we should be very hesitant to take
humans away I also am somewhat skeptical
of the feasibility of actually achieving
restraint on these topics I think it's
very unlikely the way the current
international dynamics are unfolding
which is largely focused on humanitarian
concerns and we're raiding countries and
telling them that they are not going to
build weapons that comply with
international humanitarian law I just
don't think that's a winning argument I
don't think that resonates with most of
the major military powers so I think
that when you look at actually
historical attempts to ban
that right now we're seeing as a
continuation of the most recent
historical playbook which is the
elements of civil society have got to
put pressure on countries to ban certain
weapons for humanitarian reasons I think
it's actually unusual we look at the
Broadhurst or Clark most attempts to ban
weapons were driven by great powers and
not by outsiders and most of them
centered on us for teacher concerns
concerns about someone getting an unfair
military advantage or weapons you know
sort of making war more challenging for
militaries themselves or making a life
more challenging for combatants
themselves when you say that it was
driven by powers do you mean you'd have
say two powerful countries and one there
each worried that the other will look at
an advantage and so they agreed to just
ban something in advance to avoid that
yeah so there's a couple like time
periods that kind of sort of seem most
relevant here so one would be a flurry
of attempts to control weapons that came
out of the industrial revolution around
the dawn of the 20th century these
included air balloons or basically air
delivered weapons from balloons or
airplanes submarines poison gas what was
called fulminating projectiles so you
could think of like projectiles or
bullets that have fire in them or
burning exploding bullets sawback
bayonets there was at least they were
some restraint on there used some type
of bayonet and World War one though
though it wasn't ever written down but
there seems to be historical record some
constraints right there
that was one time period and at the time
that was all driven by the great powers
at the time so these were generally
driven by the major European powers and
then Japan's Japan sort of came rising
on the international stage and was
involved as a naval power and somebody's
naval the naval treaties and the
Washington Naval Treaty is another
example of this attempts to control a
naval arms race and then of course
weather flurry of arms control treaties
during the Cold War driven by the US and
the USSR many of them were some a
bilateral many of them were both at
lateral but driven principally by those
two powers so that's not that there's
anything wrong with the current models
of NGOs and civil society pushing for
bans because it's worked and it's worked
in land mines and crossing nations I'm
not sure that the same conditions apply
in this instance a larger because in
those cases there was real humanitarian
home that was demonstrated and so you
can actually you could really I mean I
think fairly criticized countries for
not taking action because people were
being literally maimed and killed
everyday by lands illogical estimations
whereas here it's more hypothetical and
so you see people sort of extrapolating
to all sorts of possible futures and
some people saying well this is going to
be terrible but other people saying Oh
would you be great and we were wonderful
and I'm just not sure that the the
current playbook that some people are
using which is the sort of general
public pressure will work when the
weapons are still hypothetical and in
fact that they sound like science
fiction like there wasn't you know this
recent open letter that FL I was
involved in and I was sitting in the
break room
ICN before doing that short bit on this
and talking to someone about this you
said what are you going on about and I
said well you know some AI scientists
wrote a letter saying they weren't gonna
build killer robots and just I think too
many people it just doesn't sound like a
near-term trouble and that's not to say
that it's not a good thing that people
are leading into the issue I think it's
great that we're seeing people pay
attention to the issue and anticipate it
and not wait till it happens but I'm
also just not sure that the public
sentiment to put pressure on countries
will manifest maybe it will it's hard to
say but I don't think we've seen it yet
so do you think in terms of considering
this to be more near-term or farther
away our military personnel also in that
camp of thinking that it's still farther
away or within militaries is it
considered a more feasible technology in
the near term I think it depends a
little bit on how someone defines the
problem if they defining is Q as human
level intelligence then I think there's
a wide agreement but will this within
military there's probably a lot of
people though the podcast it might may
be a bearing degrees of where they think
where that might be in terms of
listeners but the military circles I
think there's a perception that that's
just not a problem in then your terminal
if what you mean is something that is
relatively simple but can go over a wide
area and identify targets and attack
them I think many military professionals
would say that the technology is very
doable today and have you seen military
striving to create that type of weaponry
like are we moving in that direction or
do you see this as something
militaries are still hesitating to move
towards yeah that's a tricky question
I'll give you my best shot and
understanding the answer to that because
I think it's a really important one and
part of it is I just don't know because
there's not great transparency and what
a lot of countries are doing I have a
fairly reasonable understanding of
what's going on the United States but
much less so in other places and
certainly in countries like
authoritarian regimes like Russia and
China it's very hard to kind of glean
from the outside what they're doing or
how they're thinking about some of these
issues I'd say that almost all major
military powers are racing forward to
invest in more robotics and autonomous
artificial intelligence I think for many
of them they have not yet made a
decision whether they will cross the
line to weapons that actually choose
their own targets to what I would call
an autonomous weapon I think for a lot
of Western countries they would agree
that there's a meaningful line there
they might parse it in different ways
the only two countries that are blue put
any public guidance out on this the
United States and Kingdom and actually
define times up in quite different ways
and so it's not clear from that to
interpret sort of how they will treat
that going forward u.s. defense leaders
have said publicly on numerous occasions
that their intention is to keep a human
in the loop but then they also often
caveat that and say well look if other
countries don't we might be forced to
follow suit so it's sort of like in the
loop for now but it's like for how long
for now might be I think it's not clear
to me whether or countries like Russia
and China even see the issue in the same
light whether they even see a line in
the same place and these some of the
public statements out of Russia for
example talking about fully roboticized
units for some Russian defense
contractors claiming to build autonomous
weapons that could do targeting on their
own you know suggests that they may just
they may not even see the light in the
same way and that's in fairness that is
a view that I hear among some military
professionals and technologists I won't
say this about jewelry of you but it is
at least a significant viewpoint the
world people will say what there's no
difference between that weapon and
autonomous weapon that can choose its
own targets and a missile today it's the
same thing and we're already there again
I don't totally agree but then is a
viewpoint that's out there and do you
think that the fact that countries have
these differing viewpoints is a good
reason to put more international
pressure on
helping some sort of regulations to try
to bring countries in line bring
everyone onto the same page yeah I mean
I'm a huge supporter of the process has
been going on at the United Nations I'm
frustrated as many are about the
slowness of the progress part of this is
a function of diplomacy but part of this
is just that they haven't been meeting
very often when you add up all of the
times over the last five years it's like
maybe in five or six weeks it means just
this is not very much time to spend
together
and part of it is of course let's be
honest it's deliberate obstinacy and a
part of many nations who wants a slow
road the progress of talks but I do
think it would be beneficial if
countries can come to some sort of
agreement about rules of the road about
what they would see is appropriate in
terms of where to go forward my view is
that we've gotten the coal comes off on
the wrong foot by focusing on this
question of whether or not to have a
legally binding treaty whether that mean
that's not all if I listen to me is how
I would have framed the discussion from
the get-go because what happens is that
many countries dig in their heels
because they don't want to sign into a
tree and so they're just like they start
from the position of I'm opposed they
don't even know what they're opposed to
they're just a post because they don't
want to sign a bank I think a better
conversation to have would be to say
let's talk about the role of autonomy
and machines and humans in lethal
decision-making in war console and let's
talk about the technology let's talk
about what it can do what it can't do
second what humans are good at and what
they're not getting at and let's think
about the role that we want humans to
play in these kinds of decisions on the
battlefield let's come up with sort of a
view of what we think right looks like
and then we can figure out what kind of
piece of paper will write it down
whether it's a piece of paper that's
legally binding
talking about what the technology
actually is and what it can do is
incredibly important and in my next
interview with Toby Walsh we try to do
just that
i'm debbie wasserman science a professor
of artificial intelligence at the
University of New South Wales which is
in Sydney Australia I'm a bit of an
accident like the rest in the sense that
I've been drawn in as a responsible
sciences to the conversation now the
challenge is the opportunities the risks
that artificial intelligence posed in
fighting war and there's many good
things that they are going to do in
terms of reducing casualties and saving
life that equally I'm very concerned
like many of my colleagues are about the
risks and oppose especially when we hand
over full control to computers we remove
humans from the loop so that will segue
nicely into the first question I had for
you and that was what first got you
thinking about lethal autonomous weapons
what first gave you reason for concern
what gave me concern about the
development of lethal scientist weapons
was to see prototype weapons being
developed and knowing the challenges
that they pose it was still a long way
away from having machines that are as
intelligent as humans and and knowing
the limitations and be very concerned
that we were handing over control to
machines that weren't technically
capable and certainly weren't morally
capable of making the right choices and
therefore - I felt a responsibility as
any scientist that we want AI to be used
for good and not for bad versus I
thought you might like many technologies
it's completely dual-use pretty much the
same algorithms that they're going to go
into your autonomous car that they're
going to identify a track and avoid
Destry ins and cyclists they're going to
go into autonomous drones are gonna
identify combatants track them and kill
them it's a very small change to turn
one algorithm into the other and we're
gonna want autonomous cars great Senate
will start I'd say lots of lives
capability to the elderly to the ends of
the disabled so they can be great
benefits for those algorithms but
equally the same algorithms can be
repositioned and used to make warfare
much more terrible and much more
terrifying and with AI we've seen some
breakthroughs in recent years just
generally speaking do any of those give
you reason to worry that these
autonomous weapons are closer than maybe
we thought they might have been five or
ten years ago or has the trajectory been
sort of consistent the recent
breakthroughs have to be put into the
context that they have been in things
like games like the game go very narrow
focused task
without uncertainty the real world
doesn't interfere when you're playing a
game of go through precise rules a very
constrained sort of actions that you
need to do and things that you need to
think about and so us it's good to see
progress in these narrow domains we're
still not making much progress is still
a huge amount to be done to build
machines that are as intelligent as that
but it's not machines as intelligent of
us I'm very worried about although that
will be in fifty or hundred years time
when we haven't that will be something
that we'll have to think about then it's
actually stupid AI think that we're
already thinking about giving
responsibility to quite stupid
algorithms and that really cannot make
the right distinctions either a
technical sense in terms of being able
to distinguish combatants and civilians
as is required by international
humanitarian law and also from a moral
ground that they really decide things
like proportionality they commit they
can't make the moral distinctions that
humans have they don't have any of the
things like empathy and and
consciousness and allow us to make those
difficult decisions that are made in the
battle if we do continue on our current
path and we aren't able to get a ban on
these weapons what concerns do you have
what do you fear will happen or what do
you anticipate what type of weapons the
problems I think with the debate is
people trying to plate the concerns that
we have into just one concern and
there's different concerns at different
points and time and different
developments of the technology so the
concerns I have in the next 10 years or
so articulate the concerns I would have
in 50 years time and the concerns I
would have in the next 10 years or so is
largely around incompetence the machines
would not be capable of making the right
distinctions and later on there are
concerns the country but as the machines
become more competent that the different
concerns that they would actually now
change the speed the duration the
accuracy of war and that they would be
very terrible weapons but any ethical
safeguards that we could at that point
got in and might be removed by bad
actors and sadly plenty of bad actors
out there who would be willing to remove
any of the episode guys that we might do
it in so there's not one concern I think
question when you hear the discussion
often it see people try and distill it
down to just a single concern of a
single pointed type and depending on the
state of the technology there Tiffan
concerns as the technology gets more
sophisticated and more mature of it but
only to begin with I would be very
concerned
rather stupid algorithm to the bastard
and they could make the right moral and
the right and technical distinctions
that are required under HR have you been
keeping track at all of what sort of
developments have been coming out of
different countries you can see if you
just go to youtube you can see there are
prototype weapons and pretty much every
theater at the battle in the air there
are autonomous drones and the a systems
have trainers drone there's now been
under development for a number of years
on the sea the US Navy's launched more
than a year ago now it's first put yet
another ship interestingly when it was
launched they said it would just have
defensive measures you use hunting for
mines I think submarines and now they're
talking about putting weapons on it and
to the sea we have will turn I'm a
summary Boeing have autonomous submarine
the size of a bus that leave to be able
to cross the Pacific fully autonomously
and on land they're a number different
autonomous weapons they're certainly
they were prototypes on Thomas tank top
on the Sentry robots and the like so
there is a bit of an arms race afternoon
and it's certainly very worrying to see
that so we're sort of locked into one of
these bad equilibria where everyone is
racing to develop ins weapons and power
just because the other side is China is
definitely one of the countries to be
worried about it's made very clear its
ambitions to seek economic military
dominance through the use in large part
in technologies like artificial loose
and it's investing very heavily to do
that
the military and commercial companies
are very tightly closed together that
will give it quite a unique position
perhaps even some technical advantages
to the development of AI especially in
the battlefield so it was quite
surprising all the UN meeting in April
were pretty surprised when China came
out and called for a ban on the
deployment almost didn't say anything
about development autonomous weapons
events and probably not as far as I
would like countries to go because if
they're deployed then you still run the
risk that they will use accidentally or
otherwise and the world is still not as
safe as if they're not actually out
there with their triggers waiting to go
so now it's interesting to see that they
made that call it's it's hard to know
whether they're just being disruptive or
whether they really do see the serious
concern that we have
I've talked to my colleagues academic
researchers in China and they've been
inserting private sympathetic to the
cause of regulating autonomous weapons
of course unfortunately China is a
country in which it's not possible in
many respects talk freely and so that
made it very clear that it would be a
career killing move for them perhaps to
speak publicly like scientists in the
West have done about these issues
nevertheless we have drawn signatures
from Hong Kong where it is possible to
speak a bit more freely which I think
demonstrates that within the scientific
community internationally across nations
that there is actually broad support for
these sorts of actions that the local
politics may prevent scientists from
speaking out in their home country a lot
of the discussion around with autonomous
weapons focuses on the humanitarian
impact but I was wondering if you could
speak at all to the potential
destabilizing effect that they could
have for countries one of the aspects
weapons I don't think is discussed
enough is quite how destabilizing they
will be as a technology then they will
be relatively easy so they're cheap to
get your hands on as I was saying when I
was in Korea most recently to the
Koreans the presence of autonomous
weapons would make South Korea even less
safe than it is today a country like
North Korea is demonstrated it's willing
to go to great lengths to obtain atomic
weapons and it would be much easier for
them to obtain up autonomous weapons and
that would put South Korea in a very
difficult situation because if they were
attacked by atomic weapons and they
weren't able to defend themselves
adequately then that would escalate and
we might well find ourselves in nuclear
conflict one that of course none of us
would like to see so they will be rather
destabilizing making weapons that fall
into the wrong hands they'll be used not
by just by the superpowers that they
used by smaller nations even rogue
States potentially they might even be
used by terrorist organizations and then
another final aspect that makes them
very destabilizing is one of attribution
if someone attacks you with autonomous
weapons it's going to be very hard to
know is attacked you it's not like you
can to bring one of the weapons down you
can open it up look inside it's not
gonna tell you who launched it there's
another radio signal you can follow back
to a base to find out who is actually
controlling this so it's going to be
very hard to work out who's attacking
you and the countries will deny them and
leave that it's hit them even when
they've attacked you so
we'll be perfect weapons of terror
perfect weapons for troubling nations to
do their troubling with one other
concern the have is as a scientist is
the risk of the field receiving a bad
reputation by the misuse of the
technology we've seen this in areas like
genetically modified crops that's the
great benefits that we might have had
about technology making crops more
disease-resistant or climate resistant
that we need in fact to deal with the
pressing problems that climate change
and growing populations put on our
planet have been negated by the fact
that people were distrustful of the
technology and we've run a similar sort
of risk I think without intelligence
that if people see the AI being used to
fight terrible Wars and to be used
against civilians and other people that
the technology will but have a stain on
it and all the many good uses and the
great potential of the technology might
be at risk because people will turn
against all sorts of developments as
hospitals and so that's another risk
another reason many of my colleagues
feel we have to speak out very vocally
to ensure that we get the benefits and
that the public doesn't turn against the
whole idea of AI being used to prove the
planet can you talk about the difference
between an AI weapon and an autonomous
weapon sure there's plenty of good
things that the military can use
artificial intelligence for in fact the
US military has historically been one of
the greatest funders of AI research
there's lots of good things you can use
artificial intelligence for in the
battlefield and house where no one
should risk a life limb clearing a mind
for a perfect job for robot if it goes
wrong and blow up the robot you can
every place the robot easily equally
filtering through all the information
coming at you making sure that you can
work out or combatants and civilians
using AI to help your situation worse
again that's a perfect job that will
actually save life stop some of the
mistakes that inevitably happen in the
fog of war and in other lots of other
areas and logistics and so on there's
lots of good things in the manatorian
age today I will be used for so I'm not
against the use of AI in military
setting I can see at great potential for
it to save lives to make wallet less
dangerous but there is a complete
difference when we look at removing
humans completely from the decision loop
in a weapon and ending up with a fully
autonomous weapon where is the machine
was making the final decision as to who
lives and who dies and as I said before
that raises many technical moral and
legal questions we shouldn't go down
that line hello hola to me you know I
think there's a very big moral argument
which is that we shouldn't hand over
those sorts of decisions that would be
taking us into a completely immoral
territory that we've never seen before
lives
warfare is a terrible thing and we
sanction it in part because we're
risking our own lives and it should be a
matter of mastering that we hand over
easily to machines is there anything
else that you think we should talk about
I think think what you talk about
whether regulating autonomous weapons
regulating AI would hinder the benefits
for peaceful of non monetary uses I'm
very unconcerned does any of my
colleagues but if we regulate autonomous
weapons that will actually hinder the
development in any way at all of the
peaceful and the good uses of AI in fact
as I mentioned earlier I'm actually much
more fearful too if we don't regulate
there will be a backlash against the
technology as a whole and that will
actually hinder the good uses of a ice
I'm completely unconcerned just like the
bans on chemical weapons have not held
back chemistry the bands on bounty
weapons have not held back biology and
the bans on nuclear weapons have not
held back and development of peaceful
uses of nuclear power so I'm completely
unconcerned as many of my colleagues are
that regulating autonomous weapons will
actually hold back the field in any way
at all in fact quite the opposite
regulations for lethal autonomous
weapons will be more effective if the
debate is framed in a more meaningful
way so I'm happy Richard Moyes could
talk about how the concept of meaningful
human control has helped move the debate
in a more focused direction I'm Richard
Moyes and I'm managing director of
article 36 which is a non-governmental
organization which focuses on issues of
weapons policy and weapons law or
internationally so to start you have
done a lot of work I think you're
credited with coining the phrase
meaningful human control and so I was
hoping you could talk a little bit about
first what are some of the complications
around sort of defining whether or not a
human is involved and in control and
maybe if you could explain some of the
human in the loop and on the loop ideas
a little bit we developed and and
started using the term meaningful human
control really as an effort to try and
get the debate on autonomous weapons
focused on the human element the form
and nature of human engagement that we
want to retain as autonomy develops in
in different aspects of weapons
functions so first of all that's a term
that's designed to try and structure the
debate towards thinking about that human
element
I suppose the most simple question that
we raised early on when proposing this
term was really a recognition that I
think everybody realizes that some form
of human control would be needed over
new weapon technologies nobody is really
proposing weapon systems that operate
without any human control whatsoever and
at the same time I think people can also
recognize that simply having a human
being pressing a button when they're
told to do so by a computer screen
without really having any understanding
of what the situation is that they're
responding to having a human simply
pressing a button without understanding
of the of the context also doesn't
really involve human control so even
though in that latter situation you
might have a human in the loop as that
phrase goes unless that human has some
substantial understanding of what the
context is and what the implications of
their actions are then simply a
pro-forma human engagement doesn't seem
sufficient either so in a way the term
meaningful human control was put forward
as a way of shifting the debate onto
that human element but also putting on
the table this question of well what's
the quality of human engagement that we
really need to see in these interactions
in order to feel that our our humanity
is being retained in the use of force so
has that been successful in helping to
frame the debate I think this sort of
terminology of course different actors
use different terms some people talk
about necessary human control or
sufficient human control or necessary
human judgment there's different word
choices there I think there are pros and
cons to those different choices but we
don't tend to get too hung up on the
specific wording that's chosen there the
key thing is that these are seen bundled
together as being a critical area now
for discussion amongst states and other
actors in multilateral diplomatic
conversation about where the limits of
autonomy and weapon systems lie I think
coming out of the group of governmental
experts meeting of the Convention on
conventional weapons that took place
earlier this year I think the conclusion
of that meeting was more or less that
this human element really does now need
to be the focus of discussion and
negotiation so one way or another I
think the debate has shifted quite
effectively on to this issue of the
human element
what are you hoping for in this upcoming
meeting or perhaps what I'm hoping for
him what we're going to get or what we
like to get might be rather different
things I would say I'd be hoping for
States to start to put forward more
substantial elaborations of what they
consider the necessary human control
human element in the use of force to be
so more substance on that policy side
would be a helpful start to give us
material where we can start to see the
differences and the similarities in
States position however I suspect that
the meeting in August is going to focus
mainly on procedural issues around the
adoption of the chairs report and the
framing of what's called the mandate for
future work of the group of governmental
experts so that probably means that
rather than so much focus on the
substance we're going to hear a lot of
procedural talk in the room that said in
the margins I think there's still a very
good opportunity for us to start to
build confidence and a sense of
partnership amongst States and
non-governmental organizations and other
actors who are keen to work towards the
negotiation of an instrument on
autonomous weapon systems I think
building that partnership between sort
of progressive states and civil society
actors and perhaps others from the
corporate sector building that
partnership is going to be critical to
developing a political dynamic for the
period ahead I'd like to go back quickly
to this idea of human control a while
back I talked with Heather Roth and she
gave this example I think was an empty
hangar problem and essentially what it
is is no one expects some military
leader to walk down to the airplane
hangar and discovered that the planes
have all gone off to war without anyone
saying something and I think that sort
of gets at some of the confusion as to
what human control looks like I mean
you'd mentioned briefly that the idea
that a computer tells the human to push
a button and human does that but even in
fully autonomous weapon systems I think
there would still be humans somewhere in
the picture and so I was wondering if
you could elaborate a little bit more on
maybe some specifics of what it looks
like for a human to have control or
maybe where it starts to get fuzzy
I think that we recognize it in the
development of weapon technologies
already we see significant levels of
automation and an degree a degree of
handing over certain functions to
sensors and to assistance from
algorithms and the like
there are a number of areas that I think
are of particular concern to us and I
think in a way this is to recognize that
a commander needs to have a sufficient
contextual understanding of where it is
that actual applications of force are
likely to occur already we have weapon
systems that might be projected over a
relatively small area and within that
area they will identify the heat shape
of a armored fighting vehicle for
example and they may direct force
against that object now that's
relatively accepted in current practice
but I think it's accepted so long as we
recognize that the area over which any
application of force may occur is
actually relatively bounded and it's
occurring relatively shortly after a
commander has initiated that mission
where I think my concerns our concerns
lie is that that model of operation
could be expanded over a greater area of
space on the ground and over a longer
period of time and as that period of
time and that area of space on the
ground increase then the ability of a
commander to actually make an informed
assessment about the likely implications
of the specific applications of force
that take place within that envelope
becomes significantly diluted to the
point of being more or less meaningless
for us this is linked also to the
concept of attacks as a term in
international law there's a legal
obligation that bears on human
commanders at the sort of unit of the
attack so there are certain legal
obligations that a human has to fulfill
for an attack now an attack doesn't mean
firing one bullet an attack could retain
a number of applications of actual force
but it seemed to us that if you simply
expand this space and the time over
which an individual weapon system can
identify target objects for itself
ultimately you're eroding that notion of
an attack which is actually a
fundamental building block of the
structure of the lawyer you're diluting
that legal framework to the point of it
arguably being meaningless so
we want to see a reasonably constrained
period of say let's call it independence
of operation for a system it may not be
fully independent but we're a commander
has the ability to sufficiently
understand the contextual parameters
within which that operation is occurring
can you speak at all since you live in
the UK on what the UK stance is on
autonomous weapons right now I would say
that the UK has so far been a somewhat
reluctant dance partner and the issue of
autonomous weapons well I do see some I
think positive signs of movement in the
UK's policy articulations recently one
of the main problems they've had in the
past is that they adopted a definition
of lethal autonomous weapon systems
which is the terminology used in the CCW
it's undetermined what this term lethal
autonomous weapon systems means that's a
sort of moving target in the debate
which makes the discussion quite
complicated but the UK adopted a
definition of that term which was
somewhat in the realm of science fiction
as far as we're concerned they describe
lethal autonomous weapon systems as
having the ability to understand a
commander's intent and I think in doing
so they were sort of suggesting and
almost sort of human-like intelligence
within this system which is a long way
away if even possible it's uncertainly a
long way away from where we are now and
we're already developments of autonomy
and weapon systems are causing legal and
sort of practical management problem so
by adopting that sort of futuristic
definition they a little bit ruled
themselves out of being able to make
constructive contributions to the actual
debate about how much human control
should there be in the use of force now
recently in certain publications the UK
has slightly opened up some space to
recognize that that definition might
actually not be so helpful and maybe
this focus on the human control element
that needs to be retained is actually
the most productive way forward now how
positive the UK will be from my
perspective in that discussion and in
talking about the level of human control
that needs to be retained I think that
remains to be seen but I think at least
they're engaging with some recognition
that that's the area where there needs
to be more policy substance
fingers crossed
I'd ask Richard about the UK's stance on
autonomous weapons but this is a global
issue so I turned to Mary Wareham and
Bonnie Daugherty for more in-depth
information about international efforts
of the United Nations to ban lethal
autonomous weapons my name's Bonnie
Daugherty I'm a senior researcher at
Human Rights Watch and also a director
of armed conflict and civilian
protection at Harvard Law School's
international human rights clinic and
I've been working on autonomous weapons
since the beginning of the campaign
doing most the research and writing
regarding the issue or human rights
watch in Harvard and this is Mary
Wareham I'm the advocacy director of the
arms division at Human Rights Watch and
I serve as the global coordinator of the
campaign to stop killer robots this is
the coalition of non-governmental
organizations that we've co-founded
towards the end of 2012 and launched in
April 2013 what prompted the formation
of their campaign to stop killer robots
well you know Rights Watch picked up
this issue we published our first report
in 2012 and our concern was the
development of this new technology that
raised a host of concerns legal concerns
compliance with international
humanitarian law and human rights law
moral concerns accountability concern
scientific concerns and so forth and so
we launched a report that was initial
foray into the issues and why trying to
preempt the development of these weapons
before they came into existence because
the genies out of the bottle it's hard
to put it back in hard to get countries
to give up the new technology maybe I
can follow up there just to establish
the campaign to stop killer robots I did
a lot of legwork in 2011 2012 talking to
a lot of the people that bonnie was
talking to for the preparation of her
report but my questions were more about
what should we do once we launch this
report do you share the same concerns
that we have at Human Rights Watch and
if so is there a need for a coordinated
international civil society coalition to
organize us going forward and to present
a united voice and position to
governments who we want to take action
on this for us to working that way in a
coalition with other non-governmental
organizations is what we do we've been
doing it for the last two decades
through on other humanitarian assignment
issues the International Campaign to Ban
Landmines the cluster munition
we find it's more effective when we all
try to work together and provide a
coordinated civil society voice and
there was strong interest and therefore
we co-founded the campaign to stop
killer robots what prompted you to
consider a ban versus your trying to I
guess I don't know what other options
there might have been so we felt from
the beginning that was needed to address
fully autonomous weapons is a
pre-emptive ban on development
production in use some people have
argued that existing laws is adequate
some people argue you only need to
regulate to limit it to certain
circumstances but in our mind a ban is
essential and that draws on past work
and other conventional weapons such as
land mines and cluster munitions and
more recently nuclear weapons the reason
for ban is that if you allow these
weapons to exist even to come into being
to be in country's Arsenal's they will
neva tably get in the hands of dictators
or rogue actors that will use them
against the law and against the rules of
morality they won't harm combatants as
well as civilians and it's it's
impossible once a weapon exists they're
restricted to a certain circumstance and
I think those who favor regulation
assume the the user will follow all the
rules and that's just not the way it
happens but we need to believe it should
be pre-emptive because once they come
into existence too late they will be
harder to control and so if you prevent
them from even happening that would be
the most effective solution and the last
point I make is that it also increases
the stigma against the weapons which can
influence even countries that aren't
party to a treaty banning them this has
proven the case in past weapons treaties
and even there's been a pre-emptive ban
on blinding lasers in the 1990s and
that's been very effective so there is
legal precedent for this and many
arguments for why a ban is the best
solution yeah there's two ways of
framing that call which is not just the
call of Human Rights which but the call
of the campaign to stop killer robots we
seek a pre-emptive ban on the
development production and use of fully
autonomous weapons that's the kind of
negative way of framing it the positive
way is that we want to retain meaningful
human control over the use of force and
over weapon systems going forward
there's a lot of interest and I'd say
convergence on those two points with
five years on since the launch of the
campaign 26 countries are now supporting
the call for a ban and
actively trying to get us there and an
even larger number of countries actually
virtually all of the ones who've spoken
today on this topic acknowledged the
need for some form of human control over
the use of force and over weapon systems
going forward and it's been interesting
to see and the five diplomatic meetings
that governments have held on this topic
since May 2014 the discussions keep
returning to the notion of human control
and the role of the human and how we can
retain that going forward because
autonomy and artificial intelligence are
going to be used by militaries what we
want to do though is draw a normative
line and provide some guidance and a
framework going forward that we can work
with you just refer to them as fully
autonomous weapons at SLI we usually
talk about lethal autonomous weapons
versus non-lethal fully autonomous
weapons and so that sort of drives me to
the question of to what extent do
definitions matter and then this is
probably a completely different question
how are lethal autonomous weapons
different from conventional weapons
the reason I'm combining these two
questions is because I'm guessing
definition does play a little bit of a
role there but I'm not sure well it's
important to have for countries to make
international law they have to have a
general common understanding of what
we're talking about but it generally in
a legal treaty last thing to be
articulate is the actual definition so
it's premature to get a detailed
technical definition but we feel that
although variety of names in the news
these autonomous weapons systems fully
autonomous weapons killer robots in
essence they're all talking about the
same thing they're all talking about a
system that can select a target and
choose to fire on that target without
meaningful human control there's already
Convergys around this definition even if
it hasn't been defined in depth in
detail in terms of conventional
munitions they are in essence the
conventional munition if they deploy
conventional weapons so it depends on
what the payload is if the fully
autonomous system were launching nuclear
weapons it would not be a conventional
weapon if it's launching or close to
missions it would be conventional so
it's it's not right to say there are not
conventional weapons and the talks being
held at the convention on conventional
weapons in Geneva the
is where governments decided to house
this topic I think it's natural the
people want to want to talk about
definitions from the beginning that's
what you do with a new topic right you
try and figure out their boundaries of
what you're discussing here and those
talks in Geneva and the reporting that
has been done to date and all of the
discourse I think has been pretty clear
that this campaign and this focus on
fully autonomous weapons is about
kinetic weapons it's not about cyber per
se it's van't actual things that can
kill people physically and it's about I
think the icrc the Red Cross has made an
important contribution with its
suggestion to focus on the critical
functions of weapon systems which is
what we were doing in the campaign we
just went calling at that but that's
this action of identifying and selecting
a target and then firing on it using
force lethal or otherwise those are the
two functions that we want to ensure
remain under human control and a
meaningful human control for some others
some other states they like to draw what
we call the very wide definition of
meaningful human control first some of
them it means good programming this nice
design a weapons review a kind of legal
review of if the weapon system will be
legal and if they can proceed to develop
it you could kind of cast a very wide
loop when you're talking about
meaningful human control but for us the
crux of the whole thing is about this
notion of selecting targets and firing
on them and so what are the concerns
that you have about this idea of
non-human control what worries you about
that of autonomy and weapon systems yeah
essentially yes we've articulated legal
concerns here at Human Rights Watch just
because that's where we always start and
that's got a Bonny's area of expertise
but you know there are much broader
concerns here that we're also worried
about too this notion of crossing a
moral line and permitting a machine to
take human life on the battlefield or in
policing or in border control in other
circumstances that's abhorrent and
that's something that the Nobel Peace
Laureates the faith leaders and the
others involved in the campaign to stop
killer robots want to prevent that for
them that's a step too far they also
worry about outsourcing killing to
machines
where's the ethics in that and then what
impact is this going to have on the
system that we have
place globally how will it be
destabilizing in various regions and as
a whole what will happen when dictators
and one-party states and military
regimes get hold of fully autonomous
weapons how will they use them how or
non-state armed groups use them another
reason human control is so important is
it humans bring judgment they bring
legal and ethical judgment based on
their innate characteristics on their
understanding of another human being of
the mores of a culture and that a robot
cannot bring certain things cannot be
programmed so for example when they're
weighing whether the military bands will
justify an attack if it causes civilian
harm they apply that judgement which
both legal and ethical and a robot won't
have that that's a human thing so losing
humanity and use of force potentially
violate the law and as well as raise
serious moral concerns that marry
disgusts I want to go back to the
process to get these weapons banned it's
been going on for quite a few years now
I was curious is that slow or is that
just sort of the normal speed for
banning a weapon look at nuclear weapons
are you know that's the example that
we're trying to avoid here we don't want
to be negotiating non-proliferation
treaty in 20 years time you know with
the small number of countries you've got
this and the other states who don't
we're at a crossroads here so yeah sorry
to interrupt you you know there have
been five meetings on this topic today
at the United Nations in Geneva but each
of those meetings has only been up to a
week long so really it's only five weeks
of talks that have happened in the last
four years that's not much time to make
a lot of progress to get everybody
around the same table understanding but
I think there's definitely been some
progress in those talks to delineate the
parameters of this issue to explore and
begin to pull apart the notion of human
control and how you can ensure that
that's retained in weapons systems and
the selection of targets in the use of
force there's a wide range of different
levels of knowledge on this issue not
just in civil society and academia and
in the public but also within
governments so there's a lot of flag
work to be done there to increase the
awareness but also the confidence of
governments to feel like they can deal
with this and what's happened especially
I think in the past year has been
increased calls to now move from
exploring the issue and talking about
the parameters of the challenge to what
are we going to do about it and that's
going to be the big debates at the next
meeting which is coming up at the end of
August is what will the recommendation
be for future work the government's
going to keep talking about this which
we hope they do but what are they gonna
do about it more importantly and we're
seeing I think a groundswell of support
now for moving towards an outcome dates
realized that they do not have the time
or the money to waste on inconclusive
deliberations and so they're meant to be
exploring options on pathways forward
but there's really not that many options
as has been mentioned you know they
states can talk about international law
and the existing rules and how they can
apply them and have more transparency
there but I think we've moved beyond
that so there's kind of a couple of
possibilities which will be debated one
is political measures political
non-binding declaration can we get
agreement on some form of principles
over human control that sounds good but
it doesn't go nearly far enough and so
we could create new international law
how did we do that in this particular
treaty at the conventional conventional
weapons you move to a negotiating
mandate and you set the objective of
negotiating a new protocol under the
Convention on conventional weapons at
the moment there has been no agreement
to move to negotiate new international
law but we're expecting that to be the
main topic of debate at the next meeting
because they have to decide now what
they're gonna do next year for us the
biggest I think developments are
happening outside of the room right now
rather than in Geneva itself there's a
lot of activity now starting to happen
in national capitals by governments to
try and figure out what their position
is on this what their policy is on this
but there's more prodding and
questioning and debate starting to
happen in national parliaments and that
has to happen in order to determine what
the government position is on this and
what's going to happen on it and then we
have the examples of the open letters
the sign on letters ethical principles
there's all sorts of new things that are
coming out in recent
weeks that I think will be relevant to
what the governments are discussing and
we hope will provide them with impetus
to move forward with focus and purpose
year so we can't put a timeline on by
when they might create a new
international treaty but we're saying
you can't do this quickly
if you put your mind to it and you say
that this is what you want to try and
achieve so we believe that if they move
to a negotiating mandate at the end of
this year they could negotiate the
treaty next year negotiating the treaty
is not the part that takes a long time
you know it's about getting everybody
into the position where they want to
create new international law the actual
process of negotiating that lourd should
be relatively Swift if it takes longer
than a year or two then it runs the risk
of turning into another set of
inconclusive deliberations that don't
produce anything so for us the goal is
absolutely crucial to get in there at
the beginning and the goal at the moment
has gone from informal talks to formal
talks but still with no option or
outcome when is some of the resistance
that you're facing to moving towards a
ban our government's worried that
they're going to miss out on a great
technology or is there some other reason
that they're resisting just to say 85
countries have spoken out on this topic
today most of them not at any great
length but just to say this is important
we're concerned we support the
international talks we have a majority
of countries now who want to move
towards negotiating new international
law who is the blockages at the moment
at the last round of talks and at the
previous ones it was basically Israel
Russia in the United States who were
saying it's premature to decide where if
these talks should lead we need to
further explore and discuss the issues
before we can make any progress for
others now they're just people are less
patient with that position and it will
be interesting to see if those three
countries in particular change their
minds here the particular treaty that
we're at the conventional conventional
weapons the states there take their
decisions by consensus which means they
can't vote there's no voting procedures
there they have to strive for consensus
where everybody in the room agrees or at
least does not object we're moving
forward so that that threat of
kind of a blocking of consensus is
always there especially from Russia but
we'll see there's no kind of pro killer
robot state which is saying we want
these things we need these things right
now at least not in the diplomatic talks
the only countries we've wanted to talk
about the potential advantages or
benefits are Israel in the United States
all of the other countries who speak
about this I'm more concerned about
understanding and coming to grips with
all of the challenges that are raised
and then figuring out what the
regulatory framework should be ambani
was there anything you would wanted to
add to that I think Mary summarize the
key points I was just gonna say that
there's some people who would argue that
we should wait and see what the
technology would bring we don't know
where it will go and our argument
counter to that is something called the
precautionary principle that even if
their scientific uncertainty about where
a technology will go there's a
significant risk of public harm which
there is in this case that the
scientific concern should not stand in
the way of action and I think that the
growing number of states that have
expressed concern about these weapons
and the majority which is the almost
consensus or the merging around the need
for human control show that there is
willingness to act at this point this
Mary said this is not a situation where
people are advocating and I think that
in the long run the agreement that there
should be human control over the use of
force will outweigh any hesitation based
on the weight C approach we had a good
proposal or not proposal but offer from
the United Nations secretary-general and
this big agenda for disarmament
framework that he launched a couple of
months ago saying that he stands ready
to support the efforts of UN member
states to elaborate new measures on
these lot anima s-- weapon systems
including legally binding arrangements
for him you know he wants States to
ensure that humans remain at all times
in control over the use of force so to
have that kind of offer of support from
the highest level at the United Nations
I think is very important and the other
recent pledges and commitments the one
by the 200 technology companies and more
than 2,600 scientists and AI experts and
other individuals committing not to
develop with autonomous weapons systems
that's a very powerful message I think
to the states that these groups and
individuals are not going to wait
speculation they're committing not to do
it and this is what they expect the
government's to do as well we also saw
the ethical principles issued by Google
in recent weeks and this pledge by the
company not to design or develop
artificial intelligence for use and
weapons all of these efforts and
initiatives are very relevant to what
states need to do going forward and this
is why we and the campaign to stop
killer robots welcomed them and
encouraged them and wants to ensure that
we have as much of a broad-based
appeal to support the government action
that we need taken can you talk a little
bit about what's happening with China
because that they've sort of supported a
ban they're listed as supporting a ban
but it's complicated it's funny because
so many other countries that have come
forward and endorsed the call for a ban
if not elicited the same amount of
attention I guess that's you know it's
obviously interesting though for China
to do this because everybody knows about
the investments that China is making in
to the military applications of
artificial intelligence and autonomy and
and we see the weapon systems that are
in developments at the moment including
swarms of very small miniature drones
and where will that head so what China
thinks about this issue matters at the
last meeting China basically endorsed
the call for a ban but said there's
always a but that their support was
limited to prohibiting use only and to
not address developments or production
so for us it's a partial ban but we put
them on the list that the campaign
maintains and they're the first state to
have an asterisk by it century saying
look China is on the ban list but it's
not you know not fully committed here
but we needed to acknowledge that
because it wasn't really the first time
that China had hinted it would support
creating new international law it has
been hinting at this in previous papers
including one that found that China's
review of existing international law
found so many questions and doubts
raised that it does see a need to create
international or specific to fully
autonomous weapons systems and China
gave the example of the binding lasers
protocol at the CCW which prohibits
laser weapons that would permanently
blind human soldiers and I think the
real news on China is that it's
now saying that existing law is
insufficient and we need to create new
international rules splits the p5 the
permanent members of the five members of
the United Nations Security Council you
have Russia in the United States arguing
that it's too early to determine what
the outcome should be and the UK Richard
can explain better exactly what the UK
wants but it seems to be satisfied with
the status quo and then France is
pursuing a political declaration but not
legally binding measures so there's
there's not unity anymore and that group
of five permanent members of the
Security Council and those states do
matter because they're some of the ones
who are best placed to be developing and
investing in increasingly autonomous
weapon systems okay and I wanted to also
ask unrelated right now what you're
trying to do what we're trying to do is
get a ban a preemptive ban on a weapon
that doesn't exist what are some
examples in the past of that having
succeeded as opposed to proving some
humanitarian disaster is the result of
the weapon
well the main precedent for that is the
pre-emptive ban on blinding lasers which
is a protocol to the convention by
conventional weapons and we did some
research a few years ago into the
motives behind the cramped abandoned
blinding lasers and many of them are the
same they raised concerns about the
ethics of permanently blinding someone
whether it's a combatant or civilian
they raise concerns about the threat of
an arms race they raise concerns that
there be a ban but that it not impede
peaceful development in that area and
that ban has been very successful and
it's not impeded peaceful use of lasers
for many many civilian purposes but it
has created a stigma against and a
legally binding ruling against using
blinding lasers so we think that that's
an excellent model for fully autonomous
weapons and it also appeared in the same
treaty at which these oil Thomas weapons
relief law autonomous weapon systems are
being discussed right now so it's a good
it's a good model to look at but yeah I
really like that paper that you did on
the other precedents for you know
retaining human control over weapons
systems the notion that looking at past
weapons that have been prohibited and
finding that
many instances it's because of the
uncontrollable effects that the weapons
create from chemical weapons and
biological and toxin ones to as you
personnel and minds where what's
deployed you cannot control them anymore
and this is the kind of notion of being
able to control the weapon system once
it's activated that is driven uh those
previous negotiations right correct
there's precedent for both the
pre-emptive and there's also precedent
for a desire to maintain human control
of our weapons and Murray said there are
several treaties chemical weapons
biological weapons and landmines all
have been banned in large part because
people and governments were concerned
about losing control over the weapons
system in essence it's the same model
here that by launching fully autonomous
weapons you'd be losing control over the
use of force so I think there's a
precedent for van and there's precedent
for a preemptive ban all of which are
applicable in a situation I talked to
pulse rate a little bit earlier and one
of the things that he talked about were
treaties that were developed as a result
of the powers that be recognizing that
the weapon would be too big of a risk
for them and so they agreed to ban a
weapon and then the other sort of
driving force for treaties was usually
civil societies and based on sort of the
general public saying this this is not
okay what role do you see for both of
those situations here there's a
multitude of reasons of why these
weapons should be banned and I think
both the ones you mentioned are valid in
this case from our point of view the
main concern is a humanitarian one and
that's civil society's focus we're
concerned about the risk to civilians
were concerned about moral issues and
those matters and that builds on pasts
what they call humanitarian disarmament
treaties treaties designed to protect
humanity through legal norms through and
and traditionally often through bands of
bands that put landmines cluster
missions and nuclear weapons there have
been other treaties that sometimes they
overlap that have been driven more for
security reasons countries that are
concerned about other nations getting
their hands on these weapons and they
feel in the long run it's better for no
one to happen for that
for others to have them certainly
chemical weapons was an example of that
this does not mean a treaty can't be
motivated for both reasons that that
often happens but I think and I think
both reasons are applicable here but
they just have come from slightly
different trajectories I mean it's
pretty amazing some of the diplomatic
talks that we've been on on killer
robots where we hear the government's
debating the ethics of whoever on art
specific weapons systems such as fully
autonomous weapons should be permitted
should be allowed it's rare that happens
normally we are dealing with the
aftermath of the consequences of
proliferation and of widespread use of
widespread production and stockpiling
this is an opportunity to do something
in advance here and it does kind of lead
to a little bit of a north-south divide
between the kind of you know the
military powers who have the resources
at their disposal to invest and
increasingly autonomous technology and
try and push the boundaries and then the
vast majority of countries who are
asking what's the point of all of this
where is the relevance of the UN Charter
which talks about general and complete
disarmament as being the ultimate
objective they ask have we lost that
goal here is the ultimate objective to
create more and better and more
sophisticated weapon systems or is it to
end war and deal with the consequences
through disarmament of warfare those are
kind of really big picture questions
that are raised in this debate and and
once that we leave to those governments
to make but I think it is indicative of
why there is so much interest in this
particular concern and that's
demonstrated by just the sheer number of
governments who are participating in the
international talks the international
talks there in the setting called a
group of governments or experts but this
is not about a you know a dozen guys
sitting around the table in a small room
this is a big plenary meeting with more
than 80 countries following engaging and
avidly trying to figure out what to do
in terms of just sort of helping people
understand how the UN works
what role does a group like the campaign
to stop killer robots play in the
upcoming meeting if ultimately the
decision is made by the states and the
nations what is your role I'm role is a
you know 24/7 all year round the
International meetings suddenly happen a
couple of times a year this would be the
second week this year most of our work
has been this year happening in capitals
and in places outside of the diplomatic
meetings because that's where you really
make progress is through the
parliamentary initiatives through
reaching the high-level political
leadership through engaging the public
through talking to the media and getting
an increased awareness about the
challenges here and the need for action
all of those things are what makes
things move inside the room with the
diplomacy because the diplomats need
instructions from capital in order to
really progress so at the meeting itself
we seek to provide a diverse delegation
that's not just people from Europe and
North America but from around the world
because this is a multilateral meeting
we need to ensure that we can reach out
and engage with all of the delegates in
the room because every country matters
on this issue and every country has
questions can we answer all those
questions probably not but we can talk
through them with those states try and
address the concerns and try and be a
valued partner in the deliberations that
are happening it's the normal way of
working for us here at Human Rights
Watch is to work alongside other
organizations through coordinated civil
society initiatives so that you don't go
to the meeting and have like 50
statements from different NGOs you have
just a few you know or just one so that
you can be absolutely clear and guiding
where you want to see the deliberations
go and the outcome that you want will be
holding side events and other efforts to
engage the delegates in different ways
as well as presenting new research and
reports I think you've got something
coming up Bonnie right we will be
releasing a new report on Martin's
clause which is a provision of
international law the Geneva Conventions
and other treaties that brings ethics
into law and it basically has two prongs
which will elaborate on the report but
talking about that countries must comply
with the principles of humanity and the
dictates of public conscience which in
short we believe fully autonomous
weapons raise concerns under both of
those we believe losing human control
will violate basic principles of
humanity and that there's the
groundswell of opposition that's growing
among Natale governments that
faith leaders scientists tech companies
academics a civil society etc all show
that the public conscience is coming out
against boy autonomous weapons and for
maintaining human control over the use
of force
to continue with this idea of ethical
issues surrounding lethal autonomous
weapons we're joined now by Peter Asaro
so I'm Peter acero I'm an associate
professor in the School of Media Studies
at the new school University in New York
City and I'm also the co-founder and
vice chair of the International
Committee for robot arms control which
is part of the leadership and steering
committee of the campaign to stop killer
robots which is a coalition of NGOs
that's working the UN and fully
autonomous weapon could you tell us a
little bit about how you got involved
with this and what first gave you cause
for concern my background is in
philosophy and computer science and I
did a lot of work in artificial
intelligence and in the philosophy of
artificial intelligence as well as the
history of science and early computing
and the development of neural networks
the sort of mathematical and
computational theories behind all of
that in the 1930s 40s 50s and 60s was my
graduate work and as part of that I got
really interested in the kind of modern
or contemporary applications of both
artificial intelligence and robotics
specifically the kind of embodied forms
of artificial intelligence which are
robotic in various ways and got really
interested in not just intelligence but
social interaction and that sort of
snowballed into thinking about robot
ethics and what seemed sort of the most
pressing issue within robot ethics was
these are violence the use of force and
whether we would allow robots to kill
people and of course the first place
that that was going to happen would be
the military so I've been thinking a lot
about the ethics of military robotics
from the perspective of Just War theory
but also a broad range of philosophical
legal perspectives as well when I got me
involved with nul Sharkey and some other
people who were interested in this from
a policy perspective and we've launched
the International Committee for robot
arms control back in 2009 and then in
2012 we got together with Human Rights
Watch and a number of other NGOs to form
the campaign to stop
so that leads into the next question I
have for you it's very broad can you
talk a little bit about what some of the
ethical issues are surrounding robots
and more specifically autonomous weapons
in warfare yeah well I think of course
there's a whole host of ethical issues
around robotics in general and privacy
safety sort of the big ones but all
sorts of more complicated ones as well
job displacement how we treat them and
the impacts on society and things like
that within the military context I think
the issues are sort of clearer in some
sense because it's mostly around these
of autonomous systems in a lethal force
so a primary question is should we allow
autonomous weapon systems to make lethal
decisions independently of human control
or human judgment however you frame that
and then sort of subsidiarity that
somewhat argue does the programming
within a system constitute that kind of
human control or decision-making from my
perspective the pre-programming doesn't
really do that and that's because I come
from a philosophical background and so
we look at you know just more theory and
you look at ethics and especially
content ethics and the requirements for
the morality of killing so killing is
generally speaking amoral but there are
certain exceptions and those are
generally self-defense or collective
self-defense in the case of war but in
order to justify that killing you need
reasons and justifications and machines
and computational reasoning at least at
this stage have developed and it's not
the type of system that has reasons it
follows rules and if certain conditions
are met and a rule was applied and a
result is obtained but making a reasoned
judgment about whether to use lethal
force or whether to take a human life
depends on a deeper understanding of
reason and I think that's a sort of
moral agency it's a moral decision
making and moral judgment that requires
capacity is that automated
decision-making systems just don't have
now maybe down the road in the future
machines will become conscious machine
understand the meaning of life Michigan
as well understand what it means to take
a life machines will be able to
recognize human beings as humans who
deserve rights that need to be respected
and systems may understand what it means
to have a duty to respect the rights of
others but simply programming rules and
two machines doesn't really do that so
from a legal perspective as well there's
no real accountability for these sorts
of systems because they're not legal
agents they're not moral agents you
cannot sue a computer or a robot you
cannot charge them with crimes and put
them in jail and things like that right
so we have an entire kind of legal
system as well as a moral framework that
assumes that humans are the responsible
agents and the ones making decisions and
as soon as you start replacing that
decision-making with automated systems
you start to create significant problems
for the regulation of these systems and
for accountability and for justice and
then that leads directly to problems of
safety and control and what kinds of
systems are going to be fielded where
they're going to be the implications of
that for international stability who's
going to have access to that what are
the implications for civilians and
civilian infrastructures that might be
targeted by these systems
I had wanted to go into some of this
legality and liability stuff that you've
brought up and you sort of give it a
nice overview of it as it is but I was
hoping you could expand a little bit on
how this becomes a liability issue and
also this is probably sort of an obvious
question but if you could touch a little
on just how complicated it is to change
the laws so that they would apply to
autonomous systems as opposed to humans
a lot of the work I've been doing under
a grant for the future life Institute
who looks at liability and the
increasingly autonomous systems I know
within a civilian domestic application
of course the big application that
everybody is looking at at the moment is
the self-driving car so you can ask this
question who's responsible when the
self-driving car creates an accident and
the way that liability law works of
course somebody somewhere is always
going to wind up being responsible the
law will find a way to hold somebody
responsible the question is whether
existing precedents and the ways of
doing things under current legal
frameworks is really just or is really
the best way going forward as we have
these kinds of increasingly autonomous
systems so in terms of folding persons
responsible and liable so under tort law
if you have an accident then you can sue
somebody system criminal law this is the
law of torts and under that then you
sort of receive monetary compensation
for damages done but ideally the person
or agents or company or what-have-you
that causes the harm is the one that
should pay of course that's not always
true and the way that liability works
those things like joint and several
liability in which even though one party
only had a small hand in causing a harm
they may have lots of money like a
government or a state or a city or
something like that and so they may
actually wind up paying far more as a
share of damages then they actually
contribute it into a problem you also
have situations of strict liability
even if your agency in causing a problem
was very limited you can still be held
fully responsible for the implications
there's some interesting parallels here
with the keeping of animals which are
kind of one of the systems in a sense
they have their minds of their own they
sort of do things on the other hand we
expect them to be well made and well
trained at least for domestic animals so
generally speaking you have liability
for harms caused by your dog or your
horse and so forth as domesticated
animal but you don't have strict
liability so you actually have to show
that maybe you've trained your dog to
attack or you failed to you know
properly train your horse or keep it
unstable or what-have-you whereas if you
keep a tiger or something like that and
it gets out and causes harm then you're
strictly liable so the question is for a
robot should you be strictly liable for
the robots that you create or the robots
that you own should corporations that
manufacture these systems be strictly
liable for all of the accidents of soft
driving cars and while that seems like a
good policy from the perspective of the
public because all the harms that are
caused by the these systems will be
compensated that can also stifle
innovation in the car sector that
doesn't seem to be a problem as it turns
out the president of Volvo said that
they will accept strict liability for
all of their self-driving cars
Tesla Motors has you know released a
number of auto pilot systems for their
cars and more or less accepted the
liability for that although there's only
been a few accidents
so the actual jurisprudence or case law
is still really emerging around that but
those are I think of technology where
the cars are very expensive there's a
lot of money to be made in self-driving
cars and so the expectation of the car
companies is that there will be very few
accidents and that they can really
afford to pay the damages for all those
accidents now is that going to be true
for personal robots so if you have a
personal assistant sort of Butler robot
who maybe goes on shopping errands and
things like that for you there's a
potential for them to cause significant
economic damage
they're probably not going to be nearly
as expensive as cars hopefully and it's
not clear that the market for them is
going to be as big and it's not clear
that companies would be able to absorb
the costs of strict liability so there's
a question of whether that's really the
best policy for those kinds of systems
then there's also questions ability of
people to modify their systems so if
you're holding company is strictly
responsible for their products then
those companies are not going to allow
consumers to modify those products in
any way right because that would affect
their ability to control them if you
want to kind of DIY culture around
autonomous systems of robotics then
you're going to see a lot of people
modify these systems reprogramming these
systems so you also want I think kind of
strict liability around anybody who does
those kinds of modifications rather than
the manufacturer and it's a sort of you
know breaks the seal and you accept the
responsibility for what happens and I
think that's sort of one side of it now
in the military side of it you don't
really have torts in the same way
there's of course a couple of extreme
issues around torts in war but generally
speaking militaries do not pay monetary
damages when they make mistakes they
accidentally blow up the wrong building
they don't pay to build a new building
that's just considered a casualty of war
and in an accident it's not even
necessarily a war crime or anything else
because you don't have these kind of
mechanisms where you can sue an invading
army for dropping a bomb in the wrong
place so the idea that liability is
going to act as an accountability
measure on autonomous systems is is just
silly
I think in warfare because you just you
can't sue people in war basically
there's a few exceptions and the
government's that purchase weapons
systems can sue the manufacturers that's
the sort of sense in which there is an
ability to do that but even most of
those cases have been largely
unsuccessful generally those kinds of
lawsuits are based on the contracts and
not the actual performance or damage is
caused by an actual system so you don't
really have that entire regulatory
mechanism so if you have a governor
that's concerned about not harming
civilians and not harming the wrong
buildings and things like that
of course then they are incentivized to
put pressure on manufacturers to build
systems that perform well and that's one
of the sort of drivers of that
technology but it's a much weaker force
if you think about you know what the
engineer is in a car company are
thinking about in terms of safety and
the kind of bottom line for their
company if they make a product that
causes accidents versus how that's
thought about in the defense company
where certainly they're trying to
protect civilians and ensure that
systems work correctly but they don't
have enormous a powerful economic
concern about lawsuits in the future so
the idea that you know the technology is
going to be driven by similar forces it
doesn't really apply and so that's a big
concern I think for the development of
autonomous systems in the military
sphere is there a worry or a risk that
this sort of I don't know if its lack of
liability maybe just it's whether or not
we can trust the systems that are being
built but is there an increased risk of
war crimes as a result of autonomous
weapons either intentionally or
accidentally yeah I mean the idea that
there's an increased risk of war crimes
is kind of an interesting question
because the answer is simultaneously yes
I know right what these autonomous
systems actually do is diminish or
remove or put a distance between the
accountability of humans and their
actions or the consequences of their
actions so if you think of the
autonomous system as a sort of
intermediary between humans and the
effects of their actions there's this
sort of accountability gap that gets
created a system could go and do some
horrendous Act for you know like
devastated village and all the civilians
in the village and then we say oh is
this a war crime and under international
law as it stands you have to prove
intention which is usually the most
difficult part of were crimes tribunals
being able to actually demonstrate in
court that a commander had the
engine of committing you know some
genocide I'll act or some war crime and
you can you know build various forms of
evidence for that now if you've sent out
an autonomous system and you may not
even know what that system is really
going to do and you don't need to know
exactly what it's going to do when you
give it orders but it becomes very easy
to sort of distance yourself legally
from what that system does in the field
and maybe you suspect it might do
something terrible and that's what you
really want but it would be very easy
then to sort of cover up your true
intentions using these kinds of systems
so on the one hand it would be much
easier to commit war crimes on the other
hand it'll be much more difficult to
prosecute or hold anybody accountable
for war crimes that would be committed
by autonomous weapons
you've also been producing some open
letters this summer there was one for
academics calling on Google to start
work on project maven and I'm sorry you
have another one what was that one about
the Amazon Facebook ignition rate
rewrite yeah yeah so I was hoping you
could talk a little bit about what you
see as the role of academics and
corporations and civil society in
general in this debate about lethal
autonomous weapons I think in terms of
the debate of lethal autonomous weapons
the civil society has a crucial role to
play I think in a broad range of
humanitarian disarmament issues and in
the case of autonomous weapons it's
really is the technology that's moving
very quickly and militaries are still a
little bit unsure of exactly how they're
going to use it but they're very excited
about it and they're putting lots of
research investment into new
applications and trying to find new ways
of using it and I think that's exciting
from a research perspective but it's
very concerning from a humanitarian and
human rights perspective because it's
again it's not clear what what kind of
legal accountability will be around
these systems it's not clear what kind
of safety control and testing might be
imposed on these systems and it's also
seems quite clear that these systems are
really made for arms races and global
and regional military destabilization
right where competitors are acquiring
these systems and that has a potential
ability to conflict because of that
destabilization itself then then of
course the rapid proliferation so in
terms of civil society's role I think
what we've been doing primarily is
voicing of the general concern I think
the broad public globally and within
specific countries that we've surveyed
are largely opposed to these systems of
course the proponents say that's just
because you've seen too many sci-fi
movies and these things are going to be
just fine but I don't think that's
really the case I think there's some
genuine fears and concerns that need to
be addressed so we've also seen the
involvement of a number of the tax
companies that are developing artificial
intelligence machine learning robotics
and things like that and I think their
interest in concerned in this issue is
is twofold we have companies like clear
path robotics which is the largest
robotics company in Canada and also the
largest supplier of robots to the
Canadian military whose engineers
organized together to say that they do
not want their systems to be used for
autonomous weapons platforms and they
will build them but they also want to
support the international campaign to
ensure that governments don't acquire
their robots and then weaponize them and
they're doing you know search and rescue
robots and bomb disposal robots
if similar movement amongst academics
and artificial intelligence and robotics
who has spent really their life work
developing these fundamental
technologies who were then deeply
concerned that the first perhaps last
application of this is going to be
autonomous weapons and that you know the
public will turn against artificial
intelligence and robotics because of
that and then that these systems are
genuinely scary and that we shouldn't
really be of trusting human lives or the
decision to take human lives to these
automated systems they have all kinds of
great practical social applications we
should be pursuing those and just leave
aside and really prohibit the use of
these systems in the military context
for autonomous targeting and now I think
we're seeing more movement from the big
companies particularly this open letter
that we were part of with Google and
their project may then the project maven
is a pentagon project the aims at
analyzing all the many thousands of
hours of drone footage that the US
military drones are collecting over
Afghanistan and Iraq and various places
where they're operating and to try to
automate using machine learning to
identify objects of interest to kind of
save time for human sensor analysts have
to pour through these images and then
try to determine what that is and in and
of itself that doesn't seem too terrible
right you're just scanning through this
imagery but of course this is really the
first step to an automated targeted
recognition system for drones so if you
wanted to fool
drones which currently require human
operators to interpret the imagery to
decide you know that this is something
that should be targeted with a weapon
and then to actually target and fire a
weapon that whole process is still
controlled by humans but if you wanted
to automate it the first thing you have
to do is automate the visual analysis
piece when some project maven is trying
to do exactly that and to do that on a
really big scale the other kind of issue
from the perspective of kind of labor
and research organization is that the
Pentagon really has trouble I think
attracting talent there's you know a
really strong demand for artificial
intelligence researchers developers
right now because there's so many
applications and there's so much
business opportunity around it that
actually turns out the military
opportunities are are not nearly as
lucrative as a lot of the other business
applications Google and Amazon and
Facebook and Microsoft can offer
enormous salaries to people with PhDs
and machine learning or even just
master's degrees or some experience and
systems development and the Pentagon
can't compete with that on government
salaries and I think they're even having
trouble getting you know certain
contracts with these companies but when
they get a contract with a company like
Google then they're able to get access
to really the top talent in artificial
intelligence and their cloud research
groups and engineering and also the sort
of enormous capacity computationally of
Google that has these massive data
centers and processing capabilities and
then you're also getting in some ways I
mean Google is a company that collects
data about people all over the world
every day all the time
every Google search that you do and
there's millions of Google searches per
second or something in the world right
so they have also the potential of
applying data that's collected from the
public in all these complicated ways
it's really a kind of a unique company
in these respects and I think as a
company that collects that kind of
private data they also have a certain
obligation to society to ensure that
that data isn't used in detrimental ways
and fighting with a single military in
the world and using data that might be
coming from
users in countries where that military
is operating
I think that's deeply problematic and we
as academics kind of lined up with the
engineers and researchers at Google who
are already protesting Google's
involvement in this project they were
concerned about their involvement in the
drone program they were concerned about
how this could be applied to autonomous
weapon systems in the future and they
were just generally concerned with
Google's attempt to become a major
military contractor and not just you
know selling a simple service like a
word processor or search which they do
anyway but actually developing
customized systems to do military
operations analyzed these these systems
and apply their engineering skills and
resources to that so we really were
joined together as academics to support
those workers the workers have passed
around an open letter and then we passed
around our letter so the Google
employees that are received of over
4,000 signatures and our letter from
academics received almost 1,200 fuschia
so we really kind of a lot of I think
mobilization or awareness and then
Google agreed to not renew that contract
so they're not dropping it they're going
to continue it till the end of the year
but they've said that they will not
renew it in the future is there anything
else that you think is important to
mention I wrote a piece last night for a
report on human dignity so I can just
give you a little prayer about human
dignity so I think the other kind of
interesting ethical question around
autonomous systems is this question of
the right to human dignity and whether
autonomous weapons are allowing robots
to kill people would violate human
dignity and I think some people have a
very simplistic notion of human dignity
that it's just some sort of or something
a property that hangs around people and
can be violated but in fact I believe
human dignity is a relation between
people honest ism or condi in view that
human dignity means that you're
respected by others as a human others
like your rights doesn't mean they can
never violate but they have to have
reasons and justifications that are
sound in order to override your rights
and in the case of human dignity of
course minute you can die in many
terrible ways on a battlefield but the
question is whether the decision to kill
you is justified and if it's not then
it's a sort of an arbitrary killing and
that means there's no reasons for it and
I think if you look at the writings of
the Special Rapporteur on extrajudicial
summary and arbitrary executions he's
written some interesting papers on this
which is essentially that all killing by
autonomous weapons would be arbitrary in
this kind of legal sense because these
systems don't have access to reasons for
killing you to know that it's actually
justified to use lethal force and again
situation and that's because they're not
reasoning in the same way that we are
but it's also because they're not human
moral agents and it's important in this
sense that they be human because it's
human dignity is something that we all
lose when it's violated so if you look
at slavery or you look at torture it's
not simply the person who's being
tortured or enslaved who is suffering
though of course they are but as in fact
all of us who lose a certain value of
human life and human dignity by the very
existence of slavery or torture and
acceptance of that but in a similar way
if we accept the killing of humans by
machines and we're really diminishing
the nature of human dignity and the
value of human life and in a broad sense
that affects everybody and I think
that's that's really true and I think we
have to really think about what it means
to have human control over these systems
to ensure that we're not violating the
rights and dignity of people when we're
engaged in armed conflict excellent I
think that was a nice addition thank you
so much predating the time to do this
today
we covered a lot of ground in these
interviews and yet we still only scratch
the surface of what's going on in the
debate on lethal autonomous weapons if
you want to learn more please visit
autonomous weapons dot org and visit the
research and reports page on the FLI
site we've also addressed some of the
common arguments we hear in favor of
lethal autonomous weapons and we explain
why we don't find those arguments
convincing if you want to learn even
more of course there's the campaign to
stop killer robots website I crack has a
lot of useful information on their site
and article 36 has good information
including their report on meaningful
human control and if you're also
concerned about a future with lethal
autonomous weapons please take a moment
to sign the pledge you can find links to
the pledge and everything else we've
talked about on the FLI page for this
podcast I want to again thank Paul Toby
Richard Mary Bonnie and Peter for taking
the time to talk about their work with
lethal autonomous weapons
and if you enjoyed this show please take
a moment to like it share it and maybe
even give it a good review I'll be back
again at the end of next month
discussing global AI policy and don't
forget that Lukas Perry also has a new
podcast on AI value alignment and a new
episode from him we'll go live in the
middle of the month
[Music]